hello and welcome today
i wanted to share with you what in my
opinion is the single most useful
decorator in python
taking a look at the code that's already
written here first we have
a function which computes the nth
fibonacci number and it does so in a
recursive fashion so it's extremely
inefficient
next in our main function we have just a
loop
going through 400 numbers just printing
out the number
and the i fibonacci number
and then at the end we print on now if i
were to actually
run this code you would see that while
the first few go very quickly
it starts grinding to a halt around 31
32 33
and essentially each number after that
takes twice as long as the number before
it
and this is because of the
you know bad implementation of the
fibonacci function that we've given here
the main problem with this
implementation is that when i compute
fib of n minus 1 well part of that
computation
is to compute fib of n minus 2. so i'm
doing a lot of
repeated work here every level down i'm
going to be repeating work that has
already been done
and then just was thrown away in a
different function call
an easy way to fix this is just by
remembering values that have already
been computed
and that's what the decorator does so
my favorite decorator in python is
the cache decorator from the funk tools
library
so funk tools is a built-in
so you don't have to install anything
and then you just hit your fibonacci
function
with cache and now let's go ahead and
try running it again
you see it goes through all 400 of them
immediately
and the reason for that was that even
though
we have this very inefficient definition
what cache does is it just remembers all
of the values
of the function that it's computed
before so if you compute fib of 398
then when i compute fib of 399
it looks up fib of 398 and 397 and it
says oh
i've already computed both of those
things instead of recomputing them using
this recursive definition it will just
use the value that it's
remembered from the previous time that
you've run the function
so i find this to be extremely useful
because it allows you to avoid repeated
computations
there's also a variant of cache called
lru cache lru stands for least recently
used
and it does essentially the same thing
but instead of storing
all previous values of the function that
you've called it with it only stores
a certain number of them so let's just
replace this with an lru cache
and give it a max size of say five
this means that it's just going to store
the five most recent values of the
function
that i've called now if i'm just running
up values of the function in a for loop
like this
then that's plenty just to do this
so still if i run the function it
completes just as fast as before
and this way i'm only using a little bit
more memory
but it's a huge speed up compared to
when there was no cash at all
so i found myself using cash or lru cash
in a lot of different projects just
anywhere
where i can see myself accidentally
repeating computations
that might take a long time that's a
great place to just throw it in
a cache or an lru cache you don't have
to do any other work
and it can provide a lot of speed up if
you know
the right place to use it